hey Caitlin hey Evan I have a topic to
propose for this podcast episode Caitlin
yes will you do a proposal podcast with
me I do hey guys welcome back to the
evident he landed a we're gonna be
talking about our proposal story we've
gotten a few questions about this during
our past few Q&A is and we've been
saving it for a podcast because it's
it's too much to talk about in midstream
yeah like honestly one of the objectives
that I had for my proposal was I want to
make a good story I never thought would
be telling it as many people as we are
today hello hopefully you don't judge me
too much thank you the only judgment you
might get is for being too thorough
oh I'm sorry everybody so I think the
way like we can start with a little bit
of context you start with the ring
because the ring has its own story I
wanted to hold the ring it's very pretty
I have a confession that goes along with
this proposal story that we've had to
shared with our parents and everything
when when we shared the proposal story
we started looking at rings you know in
the how in that story you already heard
that we had been friends for five years
yeah we knew each other really well we
knew each other really we started dating
we like had talked about all of the like
really important life things that you
want to make sure you're compatible on
before like entering a long term
relationship it was it was kind of funny
though because we shared this with each
other later after the fact but like very
soon into dating I was thinking like you
know for I always I could never really
picture my life going forward because
there are a lot of unknowns and when I
start dating you it's like things
started filling in and I like knew that
like I wanted to marry you very early on
and I think we both admitted to each
other that we felt that before we said
anything and then I'm trying to remember
the details here all the little details
but I think that we were at a mall in
San Antonio cuz Kate lived in San
Antonio I lived in Houston back then we
had a mall at a food court we were I
think yeah the big downtown mall yeah
we're we on a date
downtown at the Riverwalk and we were
walking around maybe maybe I don't know
at the food court never walking past
like a ring place and like Caitlin and I
kind of looked at each other I like
wouldn't it would it be funny I mean
like we really got into it that's how we
kind of like broached the topic of
marriage I feel like I don't I feel like
knowing else we would have talked about
it yeah I do remember so fun you think
about us back then like like tiptoeing a
little bit around like like we didn't
really tiptoe around anything we just
jumped into the dating yeah like right
away there's no games there's no like
holding anything back or anything like
that it was nice but it is so funny
think about like us when I was like so
nervous to tell you that I liked you Oh
like so nervous because we've been
friends for five years it makes sense
but when you're like good friends first
it doesn't work out it couldn't mess up
your friendship so there's a lot of I'm
more stressed than entering into a usual
typical relationship and Kaelyn was like
the type of friend that I knew that I
was gonna be friends with for a long
time it's like those are like the REA
are friends that you know like I just
really good long with this person on all
sorts of things we love hanging out
there's no drama between us
at all I'm so glad that I'm her friend
anyways um one interesting thing this is
going back a bit but saying how like we
both kind of knew even earlier than we
told each other that we wanted to marry
the other person one thing and I I
remember it specifically because like it
was part of my wedding vows yeah but I
read an excerpt from my journal where I
had written like like we haven't even
kissed yet and I know that I want to
marry him weird thing to think about
like that's so like not usual you know
that's not a very visual thing our
relationship isn't the most usual I'm
starting a backup recording like I saw
you look over and I was like oh what's
happening did we forget to record III
just like I want to capture this
conversation for me too I just love like
I just love walking down memory lane I
don't want to redo this recording this
is like special so I'm backing it up
okay we're good okay um but yeah we were
at the mall and we decided to look at
rings and I feel like after is that we
were just like on a very fun secret
message mission no we didn't tell anyone
else about because like we felt weird
admitting to other people that we were
already looking so we were long-distance
dating and every every weekend I went to
visit Caitlyn and Santonio because her
car was on its last legs yeah and
probably fairly regularly would go to
like one jeweler and then another and
then another and Kalyn had a very
specific vision in mind that formed as
we kept on kind of looking at rings and
we realized we weren't ever gonna find
it so weird because simplest ring it's
just like a circle it's a it's a
circular cut diamond I don't remember
all the like
terms fancy terms on like a raised
setting man there I I knew all the terms
at one point and then the band has like
diamonds tiny ones set in the band kind
of like on the front of it and I wanted
like the band of the engagement ring to
match the band of the wedding ring and
that's that's it it's super super simple
but I think that like it was too simple
and it didn't exist anywhere yeah
everything was like way too fancy way
too intricate for for you for me yeah
for what the vision that you had in your
mind so we custom-designed it and we
were we were so long distant dating at
that time when we chose the wedding ring
and when I went to pick it up yeah cuz
like Kaelyn and I designed it together
it was Kaitlyn and then we ordered it
while we were living apart and then when
I was visiting Kaitlyn I was like well I
need to run an errand I'll be back in a
little of it and like Kaitlyn knew what
it was what else could it be so I came
back all like really excited like oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's that's how secrets between us
work we acknowledge that this there's a
secret thing and then like I just say
hey I'm doing the secret thing
okay looks like thanks for the heads up
I'll make sure not to accidentally like
you're like working on your surprise
yeah yeah so it's like what I'm doing
something for Caitlyn's birthday or
Christmas or something I'll just like
let her know like don't come into this
room without knocking because I'm
working on a present for you yeah it's
great it's a great way to like have
secrets from each other and buy secrets
really you mean surprises surprises
surprises yeah yeah yeah it's not a
secret so um so that's the ring story
now the proposal I think we can tell
kind of from two perspectives like all
of my prep and my thought work and all
of that or Caitlyn's like how she how
she experienced and I think it'd be more
fun to just hear how you experienced it
first and if I have anything to add as
like the behind-the-scenes mastermind
then I can kind of chime in or hit on it
later yes okay
so I will start by going a few weeks
before them or a week or so before the
proposal both of our families do like a
big family reunion every other summer
and so the summer Evan proposed was
gonna be his first time attending one of
my family reunions and this makes a
small family reunion there's like 40 or
50 people there it's a lot it's a it's a
big reunion the only reason I wasn't
super intimidated is because alternating
summers there's my family Union tips
which is also like 50 people so it's
like even a little bigger it's like when
I was with Kaitlyn's family at her
family reunion I felt like I was just
that like a strange parallel dimension
of my family Union I was like this is
the exact same it was crazy yeah it was
nice and crazy in a super cool way yeah
and so going into it um you were I
remember you saying like hey so are you
gonna are you gonna like cuz I had told
I think I told my mom by that point that
like I knew you had a ring and that you
know we had talked about getting married
but I don't remember if I had told my
dad yet I mean my mom probably don't
know um but I remember you being like so
are you gonna are you gonna tell your
dad you know like kind of you know prime
the path for me
you know um like let him know ah and I
was like yeah you maybe bring it up or
something bring it up you know hahaha
you know if there'd be like a good time
at the reunion cuz like we're always
surrounded by everybody um and so we go
to the reunion super-fun and when we
when we get back so it was around in
anniversaries and so Evan hits
like hey when we when we get back home I
actually um like books I think you said
like you books dinner or something like
a date for our anniversary yeah so like
when we get home um you know we don't
have a ton of time you should go ahead
and like get ready yeah yeah because we
haven't we hadn't been on a date for a
date it was like it was like a week away
from an anniversary thing and so I was
like oh yeah awesome so um so I'm
getting ready you know we haven't even
unpacked yet we've just gotten home and
meanwhile Evan unbeknownst to me is
hiding little clues around the apartment
for a scavenger hunt is a regular well
here's the thing okay you did cute stuff
like that oh so like it wasn't that
unusual it wasn't that unusual
so I'm so I finished getting ready and
Evan like I think you handed me the
first clue oh yeah yeah yeah wait should
we get what the clue led to like the
physical thing Oh get it yeah yes we can
show that yeah okay I'm just gonna sit
here because I'm not wearing pants now I
don't wanna get off ah this is fun no no
no no no I just wanted you to have it
for the reveal
okay so so I'm finishing up getting
ready I'm all dressed in like a fancy
dress I got my makeup done and all this
I haven't hands me a clue and I'm
thinking it's like an anniversary
surprise because you doing like cute
things and clues and like presents even
if we've said we're not doing presents
it's like I mean I asked you to be my
girlfriend via a nerf gun fight yeah
that's true with clues with clues so
yeah yeah nerf gun fight and clues and
so uh so I started doing the scavenger
hunt it's like leading me around the
apartment and I still don't expect
anything and what shape are all the
clues in there cut out paper hearts hmm
like these little kind of like
geometrically shaped paper
hearts it's all the clues I'm like
collecting them and towards was it
before I got to the final clue that you
set up the camera I might have had it
running the whole time you might have
had it running the whole I don't know I
was filming you I filmed yeah yeah yeah
so I had the camera out from the
beginning to not bring any suspicions up
yeah so no I don't know we liked
documenting things this is long long
long before YouTube but we did we were
doing like one second add a video isn't
it was not uncommon for us to like film
things just don't have them reverberated
memories so I was like anything and so
he's he's give me the clues and it leads
me to this book so bonus bonus for
anyone who's watching the podcast on
YouTube and on the front it says forever
and ever and it has a picture of a heart
yes it with geometric oh yeah the clues
that were cut out I won't go through the
whole thing but it is a lot of very
sweet and cheesy poems very so sleep so
cheesy so we're sitting there what was
was I reading it to you or you I was
we're on the couch in our apartment the
cameras running I'm reading through all
these poems and like looking at the
photos and stuff and then I get to the
last 100 here's here's all the clues I
get to the last one and the last rest of
the pages are cut out like 100 pages are
cut out in the shape of a heart and in
the recessed area is the ring oh no
Caleb the last picture photo was a photo
of the ring the last picture was photos
of the ring yeah and then that's when
Caleb just started squealing very very
cute a lot of people cry I just started
going
oh so cute I loved it oh my gosh oh and
it's whole videos out of focus but it
gets the point across the point across
so yeah it was really cute um and then
so I'm thinking like oh my gosh this is
this is so sweet so cute the book the
scavenger hunt
the poems everything and then I pull out
a computer and then he pulls out a
computer and I'm like oh okay and he
pulls it out and it's all these videos
from like all my closest friends my
family members all saying like congrats
I mean Caitlyn like like so happy you're
getting married all these like
congratulation videos including my
parents you'd already talked to my dad
of course like you talked to him at the
reunion to like you know get his
blessing and stuff um even though you
had like been priming it for me that
like literally when we were on our way
back from the airport to our apartment
oh and this is another thing but when
you were like are you well thing is and
and this didn't tip Cailin off either
but my family and Kaitlyn's family were
getting together two weeks after at her
parents house yeah we're we're both of
our families were gonna be together
like everyone was gonna be together at
the time my family is living in
California and your family visits
California every year anyway and like
the area they visit is only like 20
minutes away from I'm so clever if
someone hadn't sent us all I'm so while
we're on our way back from that's when
you're at the airport to our apartment
off I can't you know like when we're in
California you need to like work on your
dad cuz like I want to talk to him soon
I'm like you know ask for his blessing
with on our relationship so that you
know I don't know how
cuz you're such a bad light I felt like
I was like
I had to do it I have Oh everything was
on the line so I I like right before I
proposed you I threw you off yeah you
like help with the tell me not suspect
probably not suspect camera and good
like she knew I had the ring I had to do
everything I can make it a surprise yeah
I still don't know well do you all
through me huh oh and then so so I I
showed you all the videos and I'm like
and you would like pre some of the
videos were recorded at the reunion like
am i from my family member and then some
you would like reset to friends and
stuff beforehand and they recorded
videos and then I told Kaitlyn to pack
her bag yep because we were gonna go and
we were indeed going out to a fancy
dinner but we're gonna go to a fancy
dinner spend the night downtown get
massages in the morning and he also
booked a photographer no no no he'd also
booked a photographer do you like a
downtown engagement photo shoot which
like was one of the things I was so
excited about is like getting engagement
like cutesy lovey dovey engagement
photos and because I had mentioned in a
passing comment like oh man I
cuz my nails often look I had mentioned
at some point how like I want my nails
to look nice to like post the wedding
the the engagement photo the eventual
engagement I just kind of wrote that
down in my little notepad he also booked
an appointment for me to get my nails
done before the photo shoot also one
thing that's interesting and I
completely understand it but a lot of
photographers don't want unedited photos
released like so women when they take
their photos they don't want like
someone sharing photos attached to that
photographer his name that aren't
looking good but I knew that Caitlyn
would want those photos right away so I
made sure to like find a photographer
that would literally hand the flash
drive over at the end of the session we
could plug it into a computer and grab
all of his raw photo files cuz Caitlyn
is an artist she's been using Photoshop
since she was 13 she knows what she's
doing so I I mean
control yeah yeah yeah she wanted the
raw I needed want the raw photos and she
want the photos right away is that right
after the photo shoot
then Kalyn could send the pretty photos
to her family right away and those are
the photos that would be shared around
because it's the first photo of the game
that gets shared around everywhere not
not the ones that like months and months
later yeah so so yeah that was another
thing I had to made make sure like okay
photographer that will give us the SD
cards so much like coordinating and I
had brought a computer to stay in a
computer and multiple SD card readers
just in case I didn't know what Fri is
he a but was it my Krusty's mini SD s SD
I don't know I have bring all the
doctors yeah and oh oh we also have
brunch Oh bro
oh and our dinner we had like the prep
the dinner that we're in like the
private wine room and then we got this
attached to the kitchen yeah well
there's a private wine room yeah then
there was we went into like the special
dining area in the kitchen for them to
like make dessert for us oh yeah super
cool yeah like so fancy the wine bottle
and we're not even like big wine people
but since we're in the wine room and it
was like a special occasion we were like
we don't really know what kind of wine
we like can you recommend something so
he gave us this wine super tasty and we
just why not ever had in my life we guys
take home the bottle and that bottle is
the bottle that like so for cooking like
you know we use a lot of olive oil and
so I have a wine bottle with a little
pour spout on it with olive oil in there
and that's the bottle from the night we
got engaged yeah maybe seen it in some
of our videos during the cooking
excitement yeah okay the ads buttoms fun
thinking back on all of it I know I got
you so good partway through the
engagement she oh yeah and they care the
the photographer's come you kept going
but we ended up getting some like super
cool photos different cool photos and
like
because it was raining there's these
fountains downtown and they turn them
off because it was raining but because
we're taking an engagement photo shoot
we're like can you turn them back on and
um we're like we just got engaged we're
getting our photos taken and so they
turned the back on for us and then we
just looked could like totally get
drenched because it was raining anyway
oh so if I was super fun um yeah like I
and it's so great to the the
photographer that we booked we just got
in his car and he had like drive from
one spot to another spot so there's why
I would just jump out take photos jump
back into the car drive to another spot
in downtown Houston there's all like
downtown Houston has like this really
cool green area and all these like cool
architecture and yeah all sorts of cool
places take photos and he knew all those
places so here the second to us to all
of his favorite downtown photo places
and we just had a wild wild like I don't
know so so what what was the most
surprising part to you I mean sorry I
don't know I put you on the spot like
for you to choose like one thing well I
think the most oh man just like the fact
that I did it right then yeah the fact
that you did it right then but if I'm if
I'm looking at the smaller elements yeah
like the more individual elements I
think one of the things that surprised
me the most was the videos from the
family oh yeah yeah yeah just cuz like
it was it was just so many and it's like
also so many people that could have
accidentally slipped up because they
knew already engaged and it's like you
know somebody closest friends I talked
to like about like knowing that we were
gonna get engaged I didn't have one
spilled the beans my mom who is really
bad at secrets did not spill the beans
at all very proud yeah very proud well I
didn't wait too far in it like I didn't
do it too far in advance I was like
smart about a week out when I asked for
all the videos it's like I was trying to
like combine like I'll try to like
obviously tailor all of this to Caitlin
and I was like what are all of her
favorite things what are everything that
she's gonna want and I knew that she was
gonna want to call every
and like share share it and everything
and I knew that she'd like want to like
have a moment like that with with
everyone but I also wanted to like you
know go out on a date and I also wanted
to get the photos and I was like there's
so many things to fit in so I tried to
like combine all of the best pieces
together to create this like experience
just for you that has all of your
favorite things like squished together
in a way like a really dense squishing
squishing of your favorite things yeah I
don't know it's fun so fun and also like
because it was such an awesome proposal
I had a lot of fun telling it over yeah
I didn't want to create like a good
story was like and then and then it was
fun to like brag on how thoughtful
the dinner was like a really special
thing and I didn't even fully know how
special yeah like like like like they
threw in like I didn't everything that
happened at that like the the dinner
that night not all of it I fully planned
for I'm not sure if I told you that I
just booked like a dinner reservation at
this like hotel restaurant in this
special room I didn't fully know that it
was attached to the kitchen I didn't
know that the chef was gonna come and
like pull us into the kitchen and cook
us dessert and all of that like a lot of
that was like they kind of got pulled
into the story along with us and they
kind of right ah this fun it's like
engagement let's make it special for
them and everything so like some like
surprises for you too yeah yeah man
feels so fine I don't want to go on a
date there again some sure no maybe
maybe maybe yeah it would be fun though
it's so fun I am because I'm think I've
been thinking about you know a lot of
people are like oh what's the first
thing you're gonna do like when things
go back to normal yeah for me the main
thing I want to do is like eat at fancy
places go on dates I want to
on dates to look like fancy I don't know
because like I mean we still are like
able to get takeout and stuff from a lot
of like places around here but like the
one thing it's a little bit harder to do
is go on like a fancy date but because
or I mean I guess we get to get takeout
food from some of these fancy places but
like some of the reason you want to go
to a fancy place for the face to feel
fancy weird there and like be out and so
like that's the thing that I've been
like craving doing with you once things
you know kind of go about a little bit
more back to normal
we'll do it yeah one thing I was
wondering did you ever picture how your
proposal would be did you have a picture
it was just gonna be at your apartment
with just your your boyfriend just
getting down on a knee and proposing in
your apartment no I cuz like if you
break it down to like the we just got
engaged at our apartment I just got down
on a knee and just asked her if she
wanted me me yeah surrounded by a whole
it was really funny like minimizing it
like that I don't know I I think cuz
like it was so much work and so much
logistics it was all you've been doing
um but yeah I don't it is interesting to
think like I didn't really have like a
vision of when you might do it all I
know all I knew is that you had the ring
yeah and that it would happen at some
you know I did like entertain oh my gosh
what have I pulled up the proposal dot
oh my gosh I don't think I've even shown
this to you I have a proposal planning
document do you have it I think I think
it's still on Drive I wonder if I can
pull up that pull it up and look at her
all your notes look at my notes of
course you would have a document of
course I'll have it but you know it but
you you yeah I'm just gonna search
proposal this is a lot of proposal
planning okay don't look
like I don't like someone use some of
this I don't know yeah for food you
surprised now looking of your notes good
I did like at one point think oh yeah
because I did think one of the things is
I was like should we go on a really nice
vacation and I set up the camera and
then like you know secretly proposed
somehow or something like that but like
I feel like you'd expect it then I have
you've expected it more I mean I want to
say yes but I also would have thought
that I was expected I think the hard
thing is like then you have to plan a
whole vacation and get to that and like
it you can't just like plan a vacation
willing because because we plan for
vacations like very it's very like loop
effort we plan everything out together
make sure that we are 100% on board with
all of the things we're both working and
like we might not have been able to do
it for months and that was like the
perfect time to do it okay this was a
little bit outdated because I still have
still need to figure out scavenger hunt
Hotel dinner photographer but like
timing during reunion to do list of like
what to do during the reunion the day we
get back set up scavenger hunt set up
camera at a filming location a video her
scavenger hunt progress put camera on
tripod read the story to her propose
play videos like I have all listed out
back for hotel go out to dinner like
nails done photographer overall fan
timing oh my gosh yeah IIIi had
different things cuz like I have an
overall plan I'll reserve a private room
that Ross goes for after but I thought I
found an even better place yeah just
like possible alternatives car service
to pick her up I'm at a hotel getting it
ready Oh what oh this is another comply
I didn't even tell you this one alt plan
that I had for the proposal is like I
came up with an excuse to leave the
reunion early or something like that so
it's like I would leave like the the
Union early you would finish it out and
then I would come back to the house
decorate everything put candles
everywhere light it up everywhere get a
car to pick you up or I would like from
the airport or something because I was
like how can I like have everything
perfect and everything already but also
like pick her up from the airport so I
was like think I could maybe have a car
pick her up but then that make her
suspicious
I don't know I'm glad you didn't do that
because that would have meant you had to
leave earlier yeah oh yeah yeah another
alternative is like I was going to tell
you that I'm making a surprise dinner
for you and you can't see what I'm
making and then like when like I would
pick you up and then when you get back
to the apartment
I'd like blindfold you take you back
into like the bedroom or something and
then like make you wait there while I
like quickly light all the candles and
like set everything up and like I was
thinking I could cook dinner for you or
I could take you know it's like all
these different things I was thinking
about like writing stickies of like
sticky notes of like all of like the
quotes that we had all the things I like
love about you because I had a list by
the way that was another alternative
thing and like cover the entire
apartment with stickies and then like I
was gonna do a path of candles leading
from the bedroom out to the main room
custom playlist of songs playing crush
and Mark have some sort of painting who
do a custom painting yeah yeah be
waiting in a huge cardboard box and have
her open it and I was gonna be in the
cardboard box yeah with the ring and
flowers or something I don't know I
don't know I have flowers waiting for I
have all these notes I have all these
I'm just thinking like the sticky notes
I feel like it would take so many more
sticky notes I feel like you buy like
like jumbo sticky notes huge sticky
notes are writing a big font I had like
a few different ways to like lead into
the proposal you know I have like some
wordings right
I don't know exactly what wording I used
but I'm not sure if it's that I don't
know because like you did you know I'm
doing the book yeah yeah but I was
thinking like I'd like get down on one
knee and then say this like really good
line and then ask you to marry me
balloons with sweet things on them oh so
I'm so sticky notes yes I was into
balloons and like sharpie on them all
sorts of things like that also thinking
about having eight notes if you're
thinking about proposing I was thinking
about like open I like giving you
because there's our anniversary and I
was gonna give you an anniversary card
for our 0 year wedding and I was like
well why wait but we didn't not getting
married that would be 0 year anniversary
of proposing SuperLab this is a
multi-page oh it's long it's really VI I
have a list of video that I wanted to
get you know a checklist and I have the
status of each marked oh yes yes
Oh scavenger hunt I had each note um
planned of like what the what was gonna
be written on the note and where I'd
hide it yeah you know yeah so handed the
first one while while she's in the
bedroom and then like you know back and
forth because they all needed to tie
together yes um I had research document
of all the places we might eat out like
a list of different places create a web
page before I proposed with funny
pictures and telling the world how much
I loved her okay planning for the book
book I think you told me about the
website idea for one anniversary didn't
I make a website I did I did make a
website for one of our anniversaries
doing like very elaborate proposal world
worthy things oh and once I faked her
out once I figure out I gave her like a
gift for it was when I gave you the
computer was it oh yeah it was when you
gave me the computer was it for it what
and it what was it for
it's for my birthday for your birthday
yeah and I did sit you down on a chair
and I got down on one knee and I like
said some corny line and then I spun you
around and there's a computer instead or
something like that so I was I think
like that might be something that like
might upset some people but because like
I knew you it's like I knew you're going
to I didn't make it to like I didn't
like making later on too much I didn't I
didn't at all no no your wife future
wife oh you have it dedicated exhibit
like words on like you know I planned
out what words are right simple copper
black white lettering heart on front
heart is geometric shapes to colors of
grey in background so print a heart on
the last 100 pages and cut them all out
try writing a poem about her I actually
did write one a poem yeah pum the back
page facing the ring will have a whole
bunch of words describing us and what I
think our relationship will be like book
content as your palm baby my poem that's
that's a long poem written out oh my
gosh old plans old plans timing trip to
see your friends after oh yeah yeah
that's just another thing I was thinking
I should we go on like a road trip to
see all of your friends after the
proposal
we'd like have like meetups in like the
two main cities where your friends were
so you get like have like little
get-together parties there man it's so
funny looking at looking at this and
like the whole long document and all the
planning and work a lot that went into
it locations picnic heart shaped
sandwiches loss of loons floating
photographer hot-air balloon ride sneak
a photographer on with us it's like
because sometimes like groups get on to
hot-air balloon
so it's like we could be a group ride on
a hot-air balloon and then like there's
a person taking photos and then they
good one - yeah I was gonna like hide
from usamma and the text you clues on
how to find me there's something I had
to thank of that and send like fun text
messages along the way on your on your
hunch towards me oh one one proposal I
had this would have been bad it would
have like taken the focus away from the
Union but I was like what if I proposed
at the Reunion that'd be crazy and then
like I like a whole bunch of envelopes
and I gave them all to her cousins and
then I'd hide and then like your
cousin's would give you all these like
envelopes or something like that it
could have been called the trouble there
is my family is so hard to wrangle yeah
Oh Oh like I thought about going into
Austin to propose oh one thing I was
gonna like I don't know I I just was
like what do you brainstorming ideas
don't cross anything out you never know
what a little heed to hangman with the
words marry me absolutely like thing -
gasps not like now that doesn't work at
all corporated somehow who knows I had
multiple things like do some art
something that's a great up above like
the wedding or like that painting silly
ideas I had a whole section for like
silly off-the-wall things get a nerf
boat paint the bow like a tree growing
from tips to branches in the feathering
get a handkerchief
fill it with glitter and the right stuff
it into the boat shoe - I get it nerf
gun that's hard to live like random
things fit balling ideas and the font on
this is eight eight point font and such
a long I know
Wow Wow I can't believe that like I
meant to show that to you that's really
fun eight years later seeing it as
really fun Wow well guys thank you for
coming along on this journey down memory
lane with us oh yes sorry for thing of
the week okay so I'll start with my
thing of the week yes and it is
fluorescent pigment I wonder if it's
chosen because we just did it for us and
pigment video on D&D dice that we made
maybe yeah it's it's it's so cool and
we've done glow powder pigment before
and we like talked about this some in
the after-show on patreon
but like fluorescent pigment is just so
much brighter and glowy er then glow
powder it's so cool so let me describe
the reston pigment glow powder when it
when it gets UV light glow powder like
charges almost like a little battery and
it slowly releases that energy back out
and because it has like an extended
release of energy it's it glows in the
dark but it's not always the brightest
and another thing is you have to use so
much of it in the pigment like if you
use a lot kind of like milky almost full
or essent powder is um I don't fully
know exactly how it works so basically
UV light is a spectrum of light that
comes from the Sun naturally and you can
get UV bulbs they're black lights now
when you have a black light you might
notice that it's not it's on but it
doesn't light up the room that much
unless it hits things that fluoresce
like white often flores's certain whites
fluoresce but basically how farest and
pigment works is the UV light shines on
it basically UV light is outputting
energy but it doesn't create much
visible light now fluorescent pigment is
specific type of life color and pigment
that energizes and like turns the energy
from the UV light into visible light of
like neon shades and that's why it glows
so right is because like it's actively
turning UV light into visible light in
this neon color where a glow powder does
it passively over time so it's just
brighter and more vivid more bang for
your buck sorry I went on a very long
time on your if you are I know a lot of
people after watching our videos have
let us know that like they're starting
to get into a resin and they're having
fun with it and experimenting man if you
want to have a party
add some fluorescent pigment yeah y'all
see strong UV lights I got some 60 watt
UV lights that I think are in the
description
those in the description of the video
alright so my thing of the week is some
good news it's a new YouTube channel
that um was created by John Krasinski
from the office who's Jim in the office
my gosh it's just so genuine wholesome
encouraging well done so so John
Krasinski was an actor in a scripted
television show and he's taken some of
like the personality and he's just like
like his good person this and he like
making YouTube videos genuinely and well
produced and everything takes different
skills and everything then like acting
in a scripted acting in a scripted way
and he did it really well he's basically
a news anchor presenting good news that
happened this week and you know at the
moment of recording there's four
episodes but it's just done so well and
it just it just makes me happy like he
does very elaborate things to like some
of us just like reporting good news that
is submitted but then I won't give
anything away but he does these much
more elaborate things to like make
somebody's day for example yeah
this was really cute and wholesome yeah
if you need to pick me up I just had
told my mom about it recently and she
texted me and she was like sgn is so
good it's so good
it might make you cry but in a really
good way happy way it also makes me want
to watch the office alright guys hope
you enjoyed today's special proposal
cast proposal cast hope you're having a
wonderful day wherever you are if you
enjoyed this episode we have plenty more
you might enjoy this is episode 58 I
can't believe it done so many podcast
episodes and if you also think someone
in your life might enjoy it would
appreciate if you shared it with them
and if you want to help the evident
Catelyn podcast out you can go to over
to iTunes or whatever your favorite
podcast app that allows you to rate
podcasts and give us I don't hide like a
5 star and be like a five star Caitlyn
hey guys hope you're having a good day
and I look forward to seeing you in the
next podcast episode